this ufc girl that lost her job did you
see this this carano girl
yeah man as a jew i think it's not good
yeah what did you have any thoughts on
it man look i think
the equivalent it is a complete false
equivalency
of her what she's making here a complete
false equivalency the fact that
she has said some things that upset
people
and are going out they're going after
her online is
not even close to what jews had to deal
with
in the 40s in germany oh yeah it's it's
not
even it's a however
the this is we we have to stop canceling
people
for having different ideas and we have
yeah that's it
even if their ideas are wrong even if
their ideas are deemed wrong yeah it's
like it's gotten to this place where
it's like
if somebody because then you end up with
a herd of people who will just never say
anything but they're angry all the time
right
and so it's nick cannon to me was the
best example
when i heard what he said i was like oh
this dude
just doesn't get he doesn't know yeah
he's yeah he's just reading like
somebody he watched some bad uh
malcolm x he's regurgitating some some
false narratives and i'm not saying
malcolm x is bad i'm saying he watched
some outtake of farrakhan or something
like
there's some videos that get passed
around even by smart people that i know
that i'm like
are you serious just sharing this
dude i could not agree with you one that
goes around it's like that oh uh
white people are afraid if black people
got in power that they would treat
white people like they treated black
people and i'm like this is insane
i haven't seen that one is that a fair
con one yeah i think it was a fair
comment but just some of the stuff that
like
i don't know just like it's just so like
i
i don't know i just i can't believe some
people would share some things that they
share you know
i i just think this scene probably first
of all unnecessary i think if you feel
like
you can't be heard which i think you can
if you have
if you have like it's not even if you're
not
like almost openly because they had that
silences violence thing
like during blm like if you're not
openly
liberal a lot of times i feel like you
definitely get stared at
for not making a lot of the same
statements you know um
this here's the thing man but like
we we're making people scared
to speak so you drive people underground
yeah and when you drive people
underground
what happens is they get angrier and
angrier and angrier and angrier
and then it probably erupts in something
like this and then something happens and
then something happens
and for me like look nick cannon was the
perfect example
when i read it i'm like this dude just
needs to be take him to auschwitz
take him to the places that can show him
exactly
what he's not hearing about this history
right and and by the way
somebody did i think julian edelman the
dude from the patriots
jew i believe he's the one who took
might have taken the canada auschwitz
and
and sat down introduced him to some
rabbis and the rabbis were like here's
the history of jews and nikken was like
got it
got it right and um but we've stopped
even allowing that
julian edelman goes at nick wright on
twitter no we've stopped allowing
there to be i've always said the number
one way you learn something is by
someone really showing you by hand
yeah and instead of like people offering
to do that now
they uh they take people's jobs away
they denounce them they make them
i don't know they like they i guess they
canceled them like i feel like yeah
maybe it's better if someone says
i think you don't understand some things
dude some people are racist
and it's hard to get through there and
some people are just ignorant to it
and angering i don't mean that in a
they're ignorant people but they're
about this thing yes i don't mean that
in a negative way right so
to me you know julian edelman
getting in there with nick cannon and
nick cannon meeting with rabbis
that's education right and so what that
does is when you cancel him you make him
angry
he hates jews more that's it's their
fault i lost my job
right and he perpetuates it instead of
that it stops there hopefully
and so and a guy with a good with a loud
microphone can be like hey this is
actually the way it is now yeah
there are some people i just don't think
you reach
oh and by the way from cool hand luke
some people you just can't reach oh yeah
so you so you get what you had here last
week
yeah um but but i think man that
it's all about being able to sit down
and talk to people yeah because
canceling people gets
it doesn't do it i think it's also
losing some of its appeal and it's
making people really turn away from a
lot of hollywood it's like
so with these people just cancel anyone
who like and it's not in this instance
you know i mean this is
i mean you know it's like some of this
seems pretty intense
but she must have felt for a long time
like she can't say anything
or she can't speak um look i don't agree
with a lot of the things that she's
posted and i don't think
any of them mean that she should have
been canceled off that show
yeah i just don't think that's the right
message to send
again when you're pushing a group of
people underground
because they think differently than you
that is dangerous that's how you have
uprisings that's how you get a bunch of
angry people
fighting back because whether it's true
or not look man it's perception
your perception of how things is are is
your reality
right whether it is reality or not right
so if you have say two million people
who feel like they're being persecuted
whether they are they aren't and being
pushed under the ground where they are
they aren't
it's gonna bubble up there's no way for
it not to yeah
and so i just feel like we're going
about this
in the wrong way a lot of times there's
some people who do deserve to get
canceled oh yeah i think there's some
people who are yeah there's people who
you know there's people all over the
place that probably deserve uh
probably definitely some sort of ca some
sort of reprimanding some sort of real
yes
action against them you know
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one